someone on your naughty list give them a
lump of coal someone on your nice list
give them a stocking full of coal don't
know what to get the libertarian on your
holiday list we've got you covered
prove you're a real libertarian with a
libertarian purity ring I'm Milton
Friedman chia-pet shock yourself awake
with the US debt alarm clock with the
free to snooze button a right to try
advent calendar filled with non
fda-approved medications that might help
why not give a subscription to the
libertarian movie of the Month Club
including classics like frosty the snow
dn't it's a wonderful life in prison for
a minor drug offense citizen Kane's the
Iran Christmas special and more how
about a gift card to eminent domain
name.com the web site that empowers you
to take someone else's website he's a
gift cards out of access a magic 8-ball
a libertarian doorbell already have a
pocket Constitution why not get a
constitution pocket to put a down
political mug shot glasses conceal your
arms with a Snuggie a Nobel Peace Prize
entitlements automatically charged to
your children controversial unisex
bathroom sign a traditional Murray
Christmas sweater cut out for the kids
on your list Rock'em Sock'em fight for
15 robots now fully automated TSA see
and say a California high-speed Model
Railroad the phase 1 system could be
completed by 2029 provided that
additional funding is obtained security
puppet theater contraband toys lawn
darts bucky balls of the Atomic Energy
Laboratory voix Gras and more your self
on the shelf because the only person
responsible for you is you a lego
micronation kit conscientious objector
sent decommissioned battleship you sunk
my port project jury nullification
Barbie hungry hungry Venezuelans mr.
potato subsidy duopoly the board game
about American politics and easy baked
oven how about an envelope full of cash
with a card explaining that the utility
of the gift exchange is maximized when
the recipient rather than the giver
dictates how the capital is allocated
it's basic economics a 3d printed gun a
4d printed gun which transcends time
itself just like the right to own one
you've had it all along for the
Objectivist lady in your life an Atlas
Shrugged needs something a little hotter
how about something from Victoria's
encrypted secret where is a letter and
love for the invisible hand Scotch need
to snazz up a dorm room we have dozens
of popular libertarian posters a dance a
naked libertarian dashboard bobblehead
off the grid repels gnats mosquitoes and
the Bureau of Land Management alt-right
troll dolls a burner phone cease dead in
a bottle christmas holsters libertarian
map of the world we hope you found this
guide helpful but don't forget the true
meaning of the holiday season taxation
is theft
[Music]